Also wenn die einzige Taktik ist
"Oh, da ist Gewalt, wir machen einen
Auslandseinsatz und jetzt bleiben wir da,
wir bleiben da so lange wie möglich.
Jetzt gehen wir wieder weg", und wie durch
ein Wunder geht es direkt weiter
und wieder werden alle unterdrückt,
dann ist das einfach anscheinend nicht
die Taktik, die am besten funktioniert.
-Ich beginne direkt mit der ersten Frage
von 13 Fragen: Sollte die Bundeswehr
weiter im Ausland eingesetzt werden?
Wenn ihr sagt Ja, auf jeden Fall
müssen Einsätze der Bundeswehr im Ausland weiter
stattfinden, dann geht ihr jetzt auf das grüne
Feld. Und wenn ihr sagt Nein,
wir müssen irgendwie Wege finden,
wie wir das in Zukunft verhindern können,
dann geht ihr bitte aufs gelbe Feld.
Wenn Soldatinnen der deutschen Bundeswehr
ins Ausland geschickt werden, dann
geht es oft darum, Terrorregime zu bekämpfen
und die Bevölkerung vor Ort
sowie Hilfsorganisationen zu schützen.
Nachdem die Taliban vor kurzem
nach einem 20-jährigen Einsatz die Macht
in Afghanistan zurückerobert haben,
stellt sich jetzt die Frage: War alles umsonst?
Und wie viel Sinn machen solche
Auslandseinsätze der NATO wirklich?
Und wenn wir sie noch brauchen,
welche Ziele sollten sie in Zukunft verfolgen?
Meine Gäste sind sich uneins. Die einen
sagen, es geht nicht ohne Auslandseinsätze
der Bundeswehr und die anderen
wiederum sind sich sicher, sie müssen endlich
ein Ende haben. Beide Seiten ringen
um Kompromisse und vielleicht am Ende ja
sogar um eine Lösung. Die erste
Frage geht jetzt aber erst mal an euch:
Auf welcher Seite des Spielfeldes
würdet ihr stehen? Gelb oder grün? Schreibt
es mir gerne in die Kommentare. Ab
jetzt, wenn ihr der anderen Seite in einem
Argument zustimmt, dann könnt ihr einfach
einen Schritt auf die andere Seite
zugehen. Und falls euch etwas aufregt
und ihr das irgendwie deutlich machen wollt
mit eurer Bewegung, dann geht ihr einen
Schritt zurück. Das könnt ihr gern
fliessenden eure Bewegungen während der Diskussion,
auch während andere Personen
reden mit einbringen. Ich freue mich
sehr auf die Diskussion mit euch und beginne
direkt mit der zweiten Frage von 13
Fragen. Andreas, die geht an dich. Du bist
insgesamt sieben Mal in Afghanistan
im Einsatz gewesen. Du musstest dort
mit ansehen, wie Kamerad*innen
von dir gefallen sind, wie afghanische
Zivilist*innen, die dir ans Herz
gewachsen sind, wie die getötet wurden. Würdest du
denn sagen, dass du persönlich
den Einsatz in Afghanistan bereust?
Ich erinnere mich natürlich, gerade
mit den Bildern aus August, sehr stark daran
zurück, was ich erlebt habe, und ich versuche
viel darüber zu sprechen,
über diese Dinge, die ich gesehen
habe, aufzuklären. Und ich bereue den Einsatz
in Afghanistan auf keinen Fall und ich würde
wieder in den Einsatz gehen
nach Afghanistan, weil ich finde, wir haben
viele gute Dinge eben auch erreicht.
Wir haben für einen gewissen
Zeitraum für eine Stabilität gesorgt
und für Sicherheit, dass Menschen
und gerade eben Frauen und Kinder
auch zur Schule gehen konnten, dass sie eine regelmäßige
Bildung erfahren,
weil nur über Bildung erreiche ich die Menschen
auch. Auslandseinsätze finde
ich total wichtig. Wir können die Menschen
nur mit der militärischen Präsenz
auch vor Ort vernünftig erreichen
und humanitäre Zwecke auch nur sichern,
wenn wir eben Militär mit robusten
Mitteln auch vor Ort haben.
Also wenn du in der Zeit zurückreisen
könntest, dann würdest du es wieder tun.
Ja. Dann an euch, die gelbe
Seite des Feldes. Ihr seid auf der Seite
gegen die Auslandseinsätze der Bundeswehr.
Was machen die Worte von Andreas mit euch?
-Geht ihr einen Schritt auf ihn zu?
-Ich habe zwischendurch mal überlegt, ob
ich einen Schritt zurück gehe, auch wenn das natürlich
nicht so soweit geht.
Gar nicht unbedingt, weil ich glaube,
dass viele Dinge dort absolut richtig sind,
die gesagt worden sind. Ich finde
den Punkt allerdings relativ spannend
zu sagen, ich würde auch jetzt noch
mal in den Einsatz gehen nach Afghanistan.
Ich glaube, dass auch natürlich
bestimmte Erfolge sicherlich erzielt werden können,
in unterschiedlichen
Einsätzen, mit unterschiedlichen Mitteln.
Aber grundsätzlich stellt sich ja
immer noch die Frage, wenn wir summa summarum
uns das Ganze angucken, was dann
letzten Endes erreicht worden ist. Meiner Meinung
nach sollte die Bundeswehr nicht
weiter im Ausland eingesetzt werden,
weil es tatsächlich jetzt der Zeitpunkt
ist, dass zivile Organisationen,
zivile Initiativen aber auch Zivilgesellschaft
gestärkt werden muss.
Ich finde ein Argument zu sagen, dass Frauen
für ein paar Jahre zur Schule gehen
konnten, ist für mich kein
solides Argument, weil ich der Meinung bin,
dass man eventuell mit anderen
Möglichkeiten, mit anderen Lösungen
deutlich bessere
Ergebnisse hätte erzielen können.
-Moritz, Michael, Ihr bleibt auch stehen.
-Meine Bewegung wäre gewesen, dass ich
denke ja, glaube ich sofort, dass du
da gewesen bist und dass das in dem Moment-
dass du das Gefühl hattest, da war
irgendwas, du hast was Gutes erreicht
und dass Leute für ein paar Jahre lang
in Sicherheit waren. Und das finde ich super
gut. Und dann hab ich aber auch sofort
gedacht, ja, aber jetzt bist du wieder
hier und alle sind wieder hier.
Meiner Meinung nach sollte die Bundeswehr nicht
weiter im Ausland eingesetzt werden,
weil ein Land, das einen Weltkrieg angefangen
hat, nicht versuchen sollte,
irgendetwas mit Waffengewalt zu lösen. Insgesamt denke
ich, wahrscheinlich hätte man das, was ihr erreicht
habt in Afghanistan als Truppe
meiner Meinung nach auch, ich will
nicht sagen anders, hätte erreichen können.
Aber die Frage im Nachhinein ist, ja,
aber war es das jetzt wert? Wenn man das misst,
an was ist an Gewalt passiert, man
hat mit Gewalt darauf geantwortet, was ist
das Ergebnis, kann man dieses Ergebnis
nicht auch irgendwie anders erreichen?
-Andreas du nickst. Was sagst du dazu?
-Erst mal vielen Dank für das, was du
gesagt hast. Und natürlich, ich bin
durchaus dafür, nach dem Sprichwort
"Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen" bin ich der erste,
der sofort Ja sagt, denn ich bin
durchaus gewillt, auch zuzuhören und meine Argumente
zu ändern. Was sehen die drei
für Möglichkeiten, in Afghanistan
oder eben im Auslandseinsatz speziell
zu erreichen, mit anderen
als militärischen Mitteln? Zala?
Du hast gesagt, man kann die Ergebnisse
anders erreichen. Und wie kann man
die Ergebnisse ohne Waffen anders
erreichen? Wie kann man sich gegen Taliban
-und Waffen kämpfen?
-Ich bin nicht so naiv zu sagen, es gibt
keinen Konflikt, wo man Menschen nicht
mit Waffen beschützen sollte. Ich bin nicht
der Meinung, dass Deutschland als Land,
als Armee das machen sollte. Es gibt so
was wie UN-Friedenstruppen, dafür
müsste man die UN umbauen. Ich verstehe
den Punkt, dass man sagt, man
möchte die Bevölkerung mit Waffen schützen,
mit Waffengewalt gegen Waffen. Alles
was danach passiert, ist stehengeblieben
bei "Jetzt bleiben wir hier mit den Waffen,
solange wie wir können. Und sobald
wir das nicht mehr können, gehen
wir wieder weg" und der Schritt fehlte
-als Bundeswehr.
-Zu dem Punkt, ob es Frieden ohne Waffen
geben kann, da sprechen wir später auf jeden
Fall auch noch ausführlich darüber.
Mattea, die Luftbrücke Kabul ist
eine zivilgesellschaftliche Initiative,
die mit Charter Flügen die Evakuierung
von Ortskräfte und Schutzbedürftigen
aus Afghanistan unterstützt hat. Und die Bundeswehr,
die ist ja auch da, um solche
Hilfsorganisationen zu schützen. Sie soll
euch eigentlich quasi den Rücken frei
machen. Würdest du
sagen, dass das funktioniert hat?
Was wir vor allem gesehen haben, ist
einerseits ein extrem schneller Rückzug
der deutschen Truppen und was wir aber
auch gesehen haben, ist
dass eine politische Agenda
selbstverständlich hinter genau
diesen Evakuierungsmaßnahmen steht
und der Unwille des deutschen Staates,
und da nehme ich jeden
Bundeswehrsoldaten mit raus, weil darüber kann ich nicht
urteilen, ich kann nicht urteilen
darüber, ob du noch mehr Menschen hättest
evakuieren wollen, aber der deutsche
Staat wollte nicht. Und das ist das Problem
meiner Meinung nach an der Bundeswehr,
dass wir uns immer wieder konfrontiert
sehen mit den staatlichen Interessen.
Und ein Soldat oder eine Soldatin kann noch so
gute Ansichten haben und noch so das Gute
wollen. Letzten Endes unterliegt es dann
aber natürlich eben immer noch dem Staat,
was dort gemacht wird. Und der Staat hat
bei der Evakuierung in Afghanistan ganz
klar gesagt: "Möglichst wenig Afghan*innen
-nach Deutschland."
-Das klingt jetzt aber danach, als wäre
wärst du dafür, dass die Bundeswehr da ist,
aber irgendwie eine andere Stelle des
Staates hat keine gute Arbeit gemacht,
aber die Bundeswehr schon. Und dann sollte
die Bundeswehr weiter in Einsätzen
sein, im Ausland. Es ist wichtig, dass sich
die Bundeswehr weiterhin im Ausland
engagiert, weil Deutschland sehr lange
davon profitiert hat, dass andere
Staaten sich militärisch eingesetzt haben
für eine friedliche Ordnung, diese aufrechtzuerhalten,
damit Deutschland sich
demokratisch und wirtschaftlich
entwickeln kann. Und Deutschland sollte jetzt
aus seiner eigenen Verantwortung
nachkommen und sich in internationalen
Verbänden mit anderen andernorts
dafür einsetzen, dass auch dort Demokratie,
Menschenrechte und Friedensabkommen
gesichert werden.
Wenn wir uns die Evakuierung
angucken, natürlich hat das da militärische Kräfte
gebraucht. Wer hätte den Flughafen
schützen sollen? In dem Falle,
wenn wir uns da historisch angucken,
was bereits passiert ist, bin ich auch bereit
zu sagen, okay, dann hätte es noch
mehr Soldatinnen und Soldaten im Einsatz hätte
geben müssen, bei den deutschen
Evakuierungen.
Du bist auch ein Schritt
auf Mattea zugegangen. Warum?
Weil Mattea hat gesagt, die wollten
gerne Menschen helfen, mehr Menschen evakuieren
lassen, nach Deutschland bringen. Und leider,
die konnten das nicht, weil durch
den Staat wurde das gesagt. Und ich finde
halt, in der Situation ist
es sehr wichtig, dass wir die Menschen
schützen und helfen,
um sie nach Deutschland oder in einen
sicheren Platz zu bringen. Es ist
sehr wichtig, dass die Bundeswehr
sich weiterhin in Afghanistan engagiert,
weil wegen der Machtübernahme von Taliban
in Afghanistan, die Situation ist
sehr schlecht geworden und alle
wünschen sich, dass Deutschland und andere Länder
-denen hilft.
-Andreas du bist auch ein Schritt auf
-Mattea zugegangen.
-Ja, weil ich die Aktion supertoll finde,
dass du unterstützt hast,
Ortskräfte auch noch zu retten mit Engagement.
Und wenn ich könnte, würde ich auch verlangen,
dass die Bundeswehr weiter
Engagement zeigt, um eben
noch mehr Menschen zu retten. Allein
für diese Evakuierungsmission. Und glaub
mir, dass der Großteil der Soldaten,
die vor Ort waren, die wären nicht
rausgezogen, wenn das nicht der Befehl
gewesen wäre und der politische Wille,
selbstverständlich nicht. Ich würde auch,
wenn ich da kurz dazwischenhaken
darf, sagen, deine Motive scheinen mir
sehr ehrenwert zu sein, aber der Auftrag,
den die Bundesregierung ursprünglich
gegeben hat, der auch eine Folge aus Nine
Eleven war, das wird ja heute auch oft
vergessen, ist ja ein ganz anderer.
Und Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer hat ja gerade
auch noch gesagt, der Einsatz war
erfolgreich, gab lange keine richtigen
Anschläge in Deutschland und so
weiter. Ich glaube nicht, dass ernsthaft
von der Politik, die Afghaninnen
und Afghanen so sehr im Fokus waren,
sondern es ging darum, quasi
Deutschland abzusichern, was man, finde ich,
auch bezweifeln kann, weil trotzdem
die Gefahr islamistischen Terrors
in Deutschland durch
Auslandseinsätze gestiegen ist. Gewalt ist keine Lösung,
das sehen wir gerade in Afghanistan,
aber das sehen wir auch in anderen Konflikten,
dass Militär nachhaltig keinen
Frieden bringen kann. Konflikte dauern an,
brechen auch immer wieder auf.
Und deswegen sind wir grundsätzlich
gegen Militär und für eine weltweite
Abrüstung.
Ich möchte gern noch mal zu der Frage
zurückkommen: Ab wann ist denn so
ein Auslandseinsatz, gerade jetzt
im Fall von Afghanistan, erfolgreich
und wann nicht? Was sind unsere Ziele?
Zala, du kommst aus Afghanistan.
Deine Mutter wurde früher politisch
verfolgt, weil sie sich für Frauenrechte
und für das Recht auf Bildung
eingesetzt hat. Und durch den Nato-Einsatz hat sich,
wie ihr alle auch schon angesprochen
hat, für viele Menschen in Afghanistan,
vor allem auch für Frauen natürlich,
das Leben für 20 Jahre sehr stark verbessert.
Jetzt ist die Taliban aber wieder an der Macht.
Wie schätzt du das persönlich ein,
Zala? Würdest du sagen,
dass der Einsatz umsonst war?
Ich denke, der Einsatz war nicht
umsonst. Der Einsatz hatte sehr gut eine positive
Auswirkung, besonders für Frauen und auch,
ich sehe persönlich für mich, es hat
sehr gute, positive Auswirkungen.
Weil im Jahr 1995, als ich geboren war,
Taliban sind gekommen nach Afghanistan
und ich durfte nicht zur Schule gehen,
mich komplett verhüllen und mir wurde
das Recht auf Bildung verboten. Und als NATO
und Vereinte Nationen und Auslandseinsatz
im Jahr 2000 gekommen war, durfte
ich wieder zur Schule gehen,
mich weiterbilden, weiterentwickeln
und ich denke, das war eine sehr gute
und positive Sache. Und es ist sehr gut,
wenn Auslandseinsätze sich weiter so
macht und weiter in Afghanistan sich engagiert.
Moritz, würdest du denn Zala in dem Punkt
zustimmen, dass wir den Erfolg von solchen
Einsätzen vielleicht nicht nur daran
messen sollten, wie viele Ziele wir dann
tatsächlich auch erreicht haben,
sondern vielleicht auch, für wie viele Menschen
wir das Leben in diesen 20
Jahren verbessert haben?
Ja, natürlich, jedem einzelnen
Menschen, den man helfen kann, das ist ein Ziel,
das man haben sollte. Und ich weiß
das, dass man so etwas wie eine Armee braucht,
um bestimmte Ziele durchzusetzen, wie zum Beispiel
Menschen, die sich nicht mehr
davor fürchten müssen, dass bewaffnete
Gruppen das Dorf überfallen. Das ist keine
Frage. Für mich ist aber die Frage,
wenn man das koppelt an drei oder vier
Nationen, die sagen "Wir machen das".
Und irgendwann sagt die Nation "Ich glaube,
die Bevölkerung hat kein Bock mehr,
dann ziehen wir uns raus", dann ist das ja
eines der Probleme. Wenn die ganze
Welt als UN sagt "Wir sind da, um den Frieden
zu schützen", dann kann die deutsche
Bundeswehr humanitär eingreifen und sagen
"Übrigens sind wir- wir sind zwar
die Welt, aber wir sind eine humanitäre
Einheit, die versucht euch
zu helfen ohne Waffengewalt".
Andreas und Sarah, ihr seid beide
einen Schritt zurückgegangen. Also wenn die UN
in einem Einsatz ist, dann ist es ja
auch so, dass da die Bundeswehr beteiligt ist,
dass da beispielsweise
Kommandofunktionen der Bundeswehr sind, dass da Fähigkeiten
der Bundeswehr auf verschiedenen
Levels einbezogen werden, weil das ist einfach
Teil davon. Aber gleichzeitig ist es auch so,
dass es Situationen gibt, wo eben
dieses Ziel, UN-Mandat, wo sich
sozusagen die ganze Welt einigt oder zumindest
irgendwie die Vetomächte im UN-Sicherheitsrat
nicht nein sagen,
das lässt sich halt nicht immer
erreichen. Wir haben auch so ein so ein Beispiel
wie Syrien zum Beispiel,
wo Chemiewaffenangriffe
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung gefahren
wurden, die massiv stärkere Auswirkungen
auch auf Frauen und Mädchen hatten.
Das ist auch nachgewiesen. Und da war es eben
eine Situation, wo Russland als Schutzmacht
gesagt hat "Wir gucken
da einfach zu". Und deswegen ist
es so, dass ich auch immer sagen würde,
der Idealfall ist ein UN-Mandat, ist
eine UN-Mission, ist eine Blauhelmmission,
so wie das auch vielerorts
aktuell der Fall ist. Mattea, du nickst?
Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich
alles vollkommen korrekt. Also ich meine,
wenn wir uns natürlich den ganzen
Apparat angucken. Ich frage mich nur, ob wir über
die UN reden oder über die Bundeswehr.
Ich glaube es sind sehr unterschiedliche
Sachen und selbstverständlich haben
wir in beiden aber genau das gleiche Problem.
Wir haben staatliche Interessen und wir haben
auch eine staatliche Agenda. Die ist
im UN-Sicherheitsrat umso präsenter
wie noch zuvor. Wir haben dort Staaten,
die Entscheidungen und Vetorechte
haben, die eben tatsächlich natürlich
selbstverständlich eigene
Interessen haben. Das gleiche können wir aber
auch ins Kleine bringen und könnem
dann nochmal wieder zurück zur Bundeswehr
kommen. Ich glaube, also du hast
vorhin gesagt, die Bundeswehr soll einerseits
wieder zurück nach Afghanistan und das Ziel
sollte sein, Menschen zu evakuieren.
Würde ich direkt zu dir aufs grüne
Feld. Also ich finde, es gibt auch andere
Lösungen, aber wenn das tatsächlich
dann am Ende das Resultat dieses Einsatzes
wäre, könnten wir da heute Abend
noch Kaffee trinken auf diesem grünen Feld.
Aber das Problem ist, das widerspricht
sich und da beißt sich nämlich die Katze
total in den Schwanz. Die Bundeswehr
kann eben nicht das, was du gesagt hast,
allein ständig machen. Die Bundeswehr
kann nicht sagen, "So, wir möchten jetzt hier
zurück in den Einsatz nach Afghanistan.
Wir möchten unsere Evakuierungsmaßnahmen
fortführen", weil immer wieder die staatliche
Agenda auf dem Spiel steht.
Und wir müssen einfach langsam
lernen, dass letzten Endes genau solche
Krisenmomente niemals losgelöst
werden können von staatlichen Interessen.
Und deswegen bin ich zum Beispiel
der Meinung, dass ich glaube, dass man
beispielsweise die Unterstützung
von zivilen Initiativen, die eben nicht
unbedingt staatlich sind, dass man die vorantreiben
kann, aber auch mithilfe des
Staates, der darf sich nämlich
natürlich nicht aus der Verantwortung ziehen.
Sarah, würdest du dann sagen, dass es diese staatlichen
Interessen gar nicht
gibt? Doch, doch, auf jeden Fall. Da sind
gewisse Dinge drin. Trotzdem, also
ich meine, was Afghanistan angeht,
also ich meine Nine Eleven ist passiert, so,
die USA haben die Entscheidung
getroffen, deshalb nach Afghanistan zu gehen. Das war
ein NATO-Bündnisfall. Deutschland hat
sich daraufhin auf diesen Terroranschlag,
der passiert ist und diese Aufforderung
der USA, dem angeschlossen. Da würde
ich jetzt nicht unterstellen,
dass Deutschland das gemacht hat,
weil es irgendwas aus Afghanistan
rausholen wollte. Aber da sind wir uns
vielleicht uneins. Aber auf was das auf jeden
Fall hindeutet, ist eben genau
die Frage, und deshalb sind wir auch heute
hier, dass es super wichtig ist,
darüber mehr zu sprechen, weil es ist
nun mal so und es stimmt, dass Leute
in Deutschland oft nicht wissen, warum ist
denn die Bundeswehr in Mali, zum Beispiel,
und es ist super wichtig,
dass man darüber jetzt redet.
Was wäre denn deine Meinung,
warum sie in Mali ist, zum Beispiel?
In Mali war ja ein ähnlicher Fall mit Terroranschlägen
in Frankreich. Und dann
die französische Armee und der Bündnisfall.
Und jetzt gibt es ja
inzwischen auch eine UN-Mission in Mali.
Also es gibt da ja verschiedene Missionen,
multinationale, unter anderem auch UN.
Und da ist das jetzt einfach so dass, das ist
ja das, wofür ihr vorhin auch wart,
eine Unsicherheit Resolution gibt, wo sich
einfach Deutschland daran beteiligt
dort. Und es gibt auch einen politischen
Friedensprozess, ein Friedensabkommen,
das zu sichern und da zu versuchen, das eben
nicht bewaffnete Gruppen irgendwie
Dörfer überfallen und so weiter, das alles,
was vorhin gefallen ist, da ist
Deutschland beteiligt. Es gibt wiederum
Einsätze in Mali, an denen Deutschland
nicht beteiligt ist, wo Frankreich stärker
offensiv Terrorismus bekämpft und wo die Bundeswehr
oder die Politik in Deutschland
gesagt hat "Nee, da machen wir nicht
mit, aber wir machen da mit." Und da gibt es ja
schon diese Differenzierung. Sarah,
ihr habt jetzt Mali angesprochen. Wir haben
jetzt viel über Afghanistan
gesprochen, aber lasst uns mal kurz grundsätzlich
rauszoomen und das Thema von außen
betrachten, also grundsätzlich
Auslandseinsätze der Bundeswehr,
denn du, Sarah, du forschst seit langer Zeit
zum Thema Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik.
Was würdest du denn sagen, ab wann ist so
ein Bundeswehreinsatz erfolgreich?
Gibt es da schon Beispiele, die du nennen
könntest? Es gibt Situationen,
wie beispielsweise Massenverbrechen
in Srebrenica und da eine Intervention,
die damals auch nicht durch
den UN-Sicherheitsrat mandatiert
war. Das ist natürlich auch eine Situation,
die sich niemand wünscht, wo aber vor Ort
einfach massiv Leute umgebracht werden,
eine Kampagne gegen bestimmte
Minderheiten,
Bevölkerungsgruppen stattfindet. Und in so
einer Situation wird dann Waffengewalt
angewendet, um zu versuchen,
das zu stoppen. Und das wäre der Fall
in Situationen, wo eben politische
Verhandlungen, wo Friedensverhandlungen
gar nicht möglich sind, wie das ja
leider häufig passiert und dann erst mal
eine Notwendigkeit ist,
einer militärischen Offensive
etwas entgegenzusetzen, um sozusagen
eine stärkere Pattsituation herbeizuführen.
Und die Frage ist dann natürlich: Wie geht
es danach weiter? Und da würde ich niemals
sagen, Afghanistan sollte das Modell
sein und sowas sollte auf jeden Fall wieder
passieren. Lass uns mal bei dem Thema
Erfolg, in Anführungszeichen, bleiben.
Michael, du bist am weitesten
hinten vom Feld von allen. Du willst nämlich
trotz diesen einzelnen Erfolgen, die Sarah
zum Beispiel gerade aufgezählt hat,
nicht nur Auslandseinsätze, sondern gleich
die ganze Bundeswehr abschaffen. Magst du
-mal erklären, warum?
-Nicht nur die Bundeswehr, sondern Militär
weltweit oder auch natürlich
Terrorgruppen und sowas,
weil wir oder meine Organisation
natürlich der Überzeugung sind,
dass es ein Menschheitsziel sein muss,
n atürlich, dass es keine Gewalt mehr gibt
und kein Militär mehr gibt. Es ist
natürlich eine Utopie, das weiß ich,
das werde ich nicht mehr erleben. Aber
ich denke schon, dass man daran arbeiten muss.
Und ich sehe gerade, oder seit
vielen Jahren, dass es natürlich total
in eine andere Richtung geht. Es wird
wieder massiv aufgerüstet und es werden
wieder Militäreinsätze geführt, von Deutschland
aus auch. Es wird immer wieder
als Normalität verkauft. Und meiner
Meinung nach werden halt auch nicht alle
Mittel, die man sonst zur Verfügung
hätte, um auch außenpolitisch zu wirken,
werden halt nicht ausgeschöpft. Jetzt
schien das ja auch so, als ob irgendwelche
Massenmorde so aus dem Nichts
passieren. Aber das hat ja alles langen Ursprung
und da könnte man ja auch zum Beispiel
präventiv reagieren. Deutschland ist immer
noch unter den Top 5 der Rüstungsexporteure
der Welt zum Beispiel.
Oder natürlich auch sowas wie Grenzen
öffnen, um Leute zu schützen und sowas,
oder natürlich auch dass viel
mehr auf Diplomatie gesetzt wird,
ziviler Friedensdienst und solche
Sachen. Also ich finde, das ist noch längst nicht
ausgeschöpft und deswegen wäre ich erst
mal froh, wenn man das ausschöpfne würde
und erst mal weniger militärisch
agieren würde, erst mal die Bundeswehr wieder
nach Deutschland holt und dann
natürlich auch international verhandelt,
internationale
Verträge schließt zur Abrüstung.
-Andreas, würdest du Michael da zustimmen?
-Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen,
entschuldige den Begriff, blauäugig
zu glauben, dass wenn wir kein Militär mehr
haben, gibt es keine Gewalt mehr. Das wäre
wünschenswert. Ganz klar. Ohne Gewalt
würden wir, glaube ich, auf dieser Welt
viel besser leben. Und die anderen Dinge,
die du angesprochen hast,
natürlich auch. Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass wenn wir das Militär abschaffen,
dass es keine Gewalt mehr gäbe, weil es gibt
immer Gruppen, die ihre Interessen
durchsetzen wollen, sei es ethnische
Gruppen oder religiöse Gruppen, die einfach
Interessen haben, die mit anderen
Gruppen wieder nicht übereingehen. Und da ist
die Frage, wie in Srebrenica, wie löse
ich solche Konflikte auf? Da sind
Menschen getötet worden unter schrecklichster Art
und Weise. Ich hab auf Bildern die Massengräber
gesehen und Leute, die dabei
waren von der UN und zuschauen
mussten, wie Leute abgemetzelt werden, die sind
bis heute noch tiefst traumatisiert.
Und ja, es wäre wünschenswert, dass wenn man-
wenn das die logische Folge wäre, ich schaff
Militär ab und es gibt dann keine
Gewalt mehr. Aber auch alle Gruppen
müssen natürlich irgendwie dafür gewonnen werden,
generell abzurüsten. Ich weiß, das ist
super schwierig, aber man darf immer nicht
nur aus dieser deutschen Sicht
sehen, sondern auch das russische Militär wird
abgeschafft, zum Beispiel, noch
weiter, und wir müssen Waffen vernichten,
zum Beispiel, und da auch abrüsten.
Ich weiß, das wird sicher natürlich erst mal
auch weiter natürlich Gewalt geben
und so was und Polizeikräfte und so was,
ich meine, die haben auch Waffen und so,
aber ist ja erst mal eine zivile Sache.
So was ist ein komplizierter
Prozess. Wie ich schon sagte, ich werde es nicht
erleben. Aber ich finde, da müsste
man zumindest mal anfangen. Zala?
Aber alle wollen keine Waffen, keinen
Krieg, alle wollen Frieden. Aber das ist
ein Traum, ohne Waffen, ohne Militär,
die Welt zu schützen. Alle wollen das,
-aber das geht halt nicht.
-Ich glaube, es funktioniert. Aber wir
müssen halt mehr dafür tun. Also ich weiß,
es klingt mega naiv, wenn man sagt,
ey- ich weiß, es klingt wie ein Traum,
wenn man sagt, ja, aber mit weniger Waffen
gibt es ja vielleicht auch weniger
Tote. Aber für mich klingt es genauso naiv
zu sagen, "Oh, da ist Gewalt,
vielleicht antworten wir mit Gewalt, und dann am Ende
ist ja vielleicht weniger Gewalt",
weil das funktioniert ja einfach nicht.
Also wenn die einzige Taktik ist "Oh,
da ist Gewalt, wir machen Auslandseinsatz.
Und jetzt, ja jetzt bleiben wir da,
wir bleiben so lange wie möglich. Jetzt gehen
wir wieder weg" und wie durch ein Wunder
geht es direkt weiter und wieder werden
alle unterdrückt, dann ist das einfach
anscheinend nicht die Taktik,
-die am besten funktioniert.
-Die Frage möchte ich direkt an euch
weitergeben. Was sagt ihr denn?
Geht Frieden ohne Waffen? Sagt ihr, ist
das total utopisch oder ist es realistisch?
Schreibt es gerne mal
in die Kommentare. Sarah, was sagst
du? Geht Frieden ohne Waffen? Ich würde mir
wünschen, dass es geht. Ich wollte
noch einen Punkt machen zu Prävention und so
weiter. Ich bin da auch irgendwie
total dafür und deswegen auch nach vorne
gegangen, dass man auch über Abrüstung
stärker reden muss, dass man sich da mehr
dafür engagieren muss und so. Ich finde,
wir sind in Deutschland vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen in einem Dilemma, weil es wurde
halt ganz lange nicht öffentlich
über die Notwendigkeit von Militärausgaben
und so weiter ausführlich gesprochen.
Und Leute wünschen sich irgendwie
alle, dass man das nicht muss. Und jetzt ist
in Deutschland- Deutschland steht
total unter dem Druck, mehr auch teilweise
für Militär auszugeben, weil Verbündete
das fordern, weil die USA das fordern.
Und ich finde das weckt in Deutschland
so ein bisschen die Wahrnehmung, dass jetzt
massiv aufgerüstet wird. Und zu dem Argument,
wenn wir immer so weitermachen,
dann bringen sich irgendwann alle um,
also ich meine, es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so,
als hätten wir international eine Politik,
wo Konflikt und Gewalt irgendwie
exponentiell steigt, sondern es gab
Initiativen wie die UN, die gegründet
wurden. Es gibt diese ganzen Formate,
es gibt internationale Verträge zur Abrüstung
und so weiter. Das passiert ja alles
und ich glaube, wir sind irgendwie alle dafür,
wie du vorhin gesagt hast, da könnten
wir da drüben Kaffee trinken,
dass das auch weiterhin passiert.
Die Frage ist halt einfach nur: Wie gehen
wir mit Situationen um, wo Deutschlands
Verbündete militärisch sich engagieren?
Soll Deutschland sich da beteiligen
oder soll Deutschland sich da rausnehmen?
Moritz sagt Nein,
geht einen Schritt zurück.
Rausnehmen. Also vor allem allein
schon die Idee von, es gibt so einen Verbund
und, du hast das Beispiel gemacht mit Amerika.
Die Amerikaner haben gesagt: "Wir
gehen nach Afghanistan." Dann gab es einen
Bündnisfall, da wurde gesagt, "Dann gehen
wir da mit hin. Haben wir einen
Plan? Werden wir schon haben." Dann kommt man
an und merkt: "Haha, niemand kennt
die Kultur. Spricht jemand die Sprache?
Nur du? Wer- ach, es gibt
verschiedene Muslime? Wer streitet denn jetzt noch?"
20 Jahre später haben wir das dann
verstanden, dass es keine gute Idee ist.
Da gibt es den Fall von Frankreich.
Das heißt, das Argument ist im Grunde
genommen: "Ja, aber wir sind so
eine Freundesgruppe, und der wurde gehauen,
und er hat gesagt, wir gehen jetzt
ihn vermöbeln, und ich denke "Ach so,
muss ich? Aber wir sind Freunde. Ja,
dann mache ich mit." Und das reicht nicht
-als Argument, um zu sagen, wir machen das.
-Aber das sind ja nicht die einzigen
Beispiele. Ich bin irgendwie total
bei euch, wenn es darum geht zu sagen,
dass in Afghanistan viel nicht gut
gelaufen ist und dass man da eine größere
Debatte darüber hätte haben sollen in Deutschland,
dass man die im nächsten Fall
auch auf jeden Fall haben muss, dass man
die jetzt wieder haben muss, wenn man
Afghanistan aufarbeitet, wenn man den Mali
Einsatz potenziell verlängert. Und da gibt
es ja jetzt auch schon die Richtung,
dass man sagt, da müssen wir lieber noch mal
drüber nachdenken, bin ich total dafür.
Ich höre hier die ganze Zeit, wir brauchen
eine größere Debatte, das nehme ich schon
mal mit zur Kompromissrunde später.
Ich würde gern mit euch noch über
realistische Alternativen der Bundeswehr
sprechen. Moritz, du bist nämlich,
du hast es gerade schon deutlich gemacht,
gegen militärische Auslandseinsätze.
Du würdest das Geld wahrscheinlich eher
für eine humanitäre Armee ausgeben.
Wie könnte die denn aussehen? Was wäre das,
-eine humanitäre Armee?
-Also ich glaube, dass es bestimmte Sachen
gibt, die die Bundeswehr schon
jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr gut kann
und was sie auch ohne Waffen weiter
tun könnte. So etwas wie medizinische Hilfe.
Es ist wahrscheinlich, du gibst mir
wahrscheinlich recht, dass die Bundeswehr
ganz gut aufgestellt ist, vor allem in medizinischer
Hilfe, die dann da angewandt
werden kann, wo man nicht in einem
ausgebauten OP-Saal sitzt,
sondern an Orten, wo nicht allzu
gute Bedingungen herrschen. Ich schätze mal,
dass die- oder ich weiß meine Familie,
ich habe einige Soldaten in meiner Familie-
Organisation, das ist so ein Ding bei der Armee,
also das kriegen die ja ganz gut
hin zu sagen, pass auf, wir haben
Organisationen, da sind Leute
und das machen wir jetzt straff und jeder
weiß, was zu tun ist. Und da macht man
das und dann kommt man ans Ziel.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich etwas, was man
in sehr sehr vielen
Katastrophenschutzgebieten genau
das bräuchte. Ich bin nicht dafür zu sagen
"Ab morgen sind alle Soldat*innen,
nehmt eure Waffen, ihr seid entlassen,
ihr geht nach Hause." Aber ab übermorgen?
Nein, nein. Ich finde, diese Menschen
haben sehr gute Fähigkeiten gelernt.
Viele gehen anscheinend in die Armee um zu sagen
"Ich möchte Leuten helfen" und dann
kann man diese Menschen nutzen, damit
diese Leute ohne Waffen anderen Menschen
helfen können. Was wir jetzt
machen mit wir schicken keine Menschen
sondern wir schicken
Material, schicken vielleicht noch mal
ein Krankenhausflugzeug. Das sollte
nicht aufhören. Aber vielleicht hören
wir auf Panzer zu kaufen und kaufen
irgendwas, was erstens danach
auch funktioniert und zweitens ein bisschen
sinnvoller Aufgaben hat als "Hey,
jetzt kann ich billig jeden
abknallen, den ich sehe." Andreas, kannst du dir
das vorstellen, was Moritz
da gerade gesagt hat? Durchaus.
Auch meine persönliche Einstellung
ist, wir können humanitär viel mehr leisten,
als militärisch im Auslandseinsatz.
Das habt ihr alle gesagt. Wir sind überhaupt
nicht dafür ausgerüstet,
militärisch einzugreifen. Das kann auch nicht
unser Auftrag sein. Mein Auftrag
oder meine Zielrichtung war es immer,
wenn ich persönlich mich
entschieden habe, in den Auslandseinsatz zu gehen,
in den Kosovo und nach Afghanistan,
war es immer dafür, meinen kleinen Teil dazu
beizutragen, dass Menschen in Sicherheit
leben können. Und natürlich sollen
auch Fluchtursachen bekämpft werden
damit. Das heißt nicht, dass ich keine Menschen
aufnehmen möchte. Aber was ich als erstes
machen muss, ist eben Fluchtursachen
bekämpfen, indem ich Sicherheit
schaffe in dem Land, dass die Menschen eben nicht
flüchten müssen, sondern sie möchten
ihre Heimat nicht verlassen. Wenn man mit ganz
vielen Menschen spricht, aus Afghanistan,
das Größte wäre, in ihrem Land zu bleiben
und in einem friedlichen Land
zu leben. Und das ist die Frage,
wie ich das erreiche. Wenn ich humanitär
eingreifen muss, dann gibt
es auch Gruppen, die dagegen sind.
Und um das zu unterstützen und zu schützen,
brauche ich eben Militär. Und wenn ich das nicht
mit Panzern mache, dann ist
das für mich vollkommen in Ordnung,
dass ich das mit Sanität mache
und dass ich das mit Pionieren mache
und dort Brücken baue, Zufahrtswege schaffe,
Wege planiere, Flächen planiere, um dort
was hin zu bauen, Krankenhäuser zu bauen,
eine Infrastruktur aufzubauen. Und dafür
nutze ich eben das Know how auch,
unter anderem, der Bundeswehr.
Dann ist das gut, weil ich glaube nicht,
dass es irgendeinen Soldat gibt, der geil
darauf ist, Menschen zu töten. Kenn
-ich zumindest nicht.
-Mattea, du bist einen Schritt
-zurückgegangen.
-Ich werde bei Fluchtursachen bekämpfen
sehr allergisch, da- ich glaube, das ist
jetzt noch mal eine ganz andere Debatte.
Aber ich finde es immer sehr interessant,
weil ich glaube, über das Argument
der Fluchtursachenbekämpfung, was ja
ein valides ist, natürlich, ich möchte
auch nicht, dass Menschen fliehen
müssen, kommen wir aber ganz schnell natürlich
auch in eine realpolitische- ja,
Realpolitik, letzten Endes unter anderem
auch der deutschen Bundesregierung.
Und ich frage mich dann immer: Ist es denn
wirklich die Aufgabe der deutschen
Bundesregierung, Fluchtursachen
zu bekämpfen? Und letzten Endes ja
immer wieder, und das haben wir ja auch gesehen,
mit Werten des globalen Nordens und mit Werten
der Demokratie und Liebe in Länder
zu gehen, die auf ganz anderen
kulturellen Werten ja auch beruhen. Also wir kennen
diese Diskussion aus den USA, dass viele
Soldatinnen und Soldaten am Ende gesagt
haben "Die Demokratie kann man den Leuten
auf den Teller legen, aber vielleicht
haben sie trotzdem Lust, was anderes
zu essen, oder bzw. vielleicht sind
sie einfach nicht bereit, dafür
komplett amerikanische Ideen und Vorstellungen
zu übernehmen." Und ich glaube,
Fluchtursachen bekämpfen in der deutschen
Politik bedeutet vorrangig, erst
mal deutsche Systeme, westliche Systeme
aufzustülpen auf Länder des
globalen Südens. Und das haben wir natürlich
wahrhaftig in den letzten Jahren ja
auch gesehen. Und ich glaube, ein Mensch
in Uniform wird immer ein Fremdkörper
sein in einer anderen Kultur. Es ist völlig
egal, ob das jetzt in Afghanistan ist,
in Mali ist, oder in dem nächsten Einsatz,
wo auch immer. Ein Mensch
in Uniform wird nie auf Augenhöhe
mit der Zivilgesellschaft sein können.
Und ein Mensch in Uniform wird niemals einen
Zivilisten oder eine Zivilistin
davon überzeugen, doch in diesem Land
zu bleiben. Da bin
ich fest davon überzeugt.
Zala, ich würde die Frage gerne an dich
weiterleiten. Hattest du denn das Gefühl,
dass da westliche Werte Afghanistan
übergestülpt werden sollten, die nicht
-erwünscht waren?
-Die westliche Werte sind nicht so komplett
erwünscht in Afghanistan, weil afghanische
Menschen sind Muslime und die haben
ihre eigenen Werte und die möchten
Menschen leben, wie sie es vorher gemacht
haben, auch in der Zukunft. Aber
ich denke, unser Problem ist jetzt,
die afghanische Menschen kämpfen um ihre Rechte
auf Bildung, auf die Arbeit
zu gehen. Die Frauen wollen nicht
die westliche Werte, sondern die wollen
zur Schule gehen, zur Universität
gehen, arbeiten, in der Gesellschaft gesehen
zu werden. Sie wollen
Mitspracherecht haben, sich politisch engagieren. Aber
die Frauen, das afghanische
Frauenproblem ist nicht nur die Kleidung. Die wollen
sich nicht westlich
bekleiden. Die wollen einfach was lernen,
was in der Gesellschaft machen,
von Menschen gehört werden. Das ist
-das Problem in Afghanistan. Moritz?
-Ja, aber genau das ist der Punkt. Vor
zwanzig Jahren wurden Frauen in Afghanistan
unterdrückt. Dann haben
wir gesagt, jetzt marschieren wir da aber
ein, jetzt marschieren wir da raus und 20
Jahre später werden jetzt wieder
Frauen unterdrückt. Und irgendwie ist man dann
nicht bereit zu sagen, dass der Militäreinsatz
villeicht nicht so
-erfolgreich war.
-Aber trotzdem kann man dann ja nicht
sagen, dass die afghanische Bevölkerung
das nicht wollte, sondern zur afghanischen
-Bevölkerung gehören ja Frauen, die-
-Da kann ich sowieso nicht zu sagen, ich
bin Deutscher in Deutschland. Ich kann
mir nicht anmaßen zu sagen: Aber die Afghanen
wollen doch... keine Ahnung.
Ich war da nicht, das weiß ich nicht.
Also ich finde es total schwierig,
darüber zu diskutieren, weil ich glaube, wir reden
hier über eine Situation, die du am besten
kennst oder du warst natürlich auch oft
vor Ort aus einer anderen Perspektive.
Ich tue mich extrem schwer, mich hinzustellen
und zu sagen "Das und das ist es,
was wir brauchen, um den Menschen zu helfen
in deren Situationen." Ich kann gerne
jetzt hier irgendwie ein paar vermeintlich
schlaue Dinge über Mali sagen,
aber letzten Endes habe ich keine Ahnung,
weil ich faktisch natürlich nicht vor Ort
bin und ich glaube, das ist erst mal
das Ding. Also tatsächlich ist der erste
Schritt, den wir machen müssen, den Dialog
zu finden mit den Menschen, die betroffen
sind und das passiert in Deutschland
einfach zu selten, das passiert
auch innerhalb der Bundeswehr zu selten.
Aber ich glaube bevor wir größtenteils
weiße Europäer*innen uns darüber
unterhalten, was wir tun können,
müssen wir in den Dialog treten mit wirklich
den Leuten, die sich kulturell
auskennen, die von dort sind, weil wir tun jetzt
nichts anderes als das, was die Bundeswehr
seit Jahren tut, nämlich über Orte
zu urteilen und unsere Vorstellungen
genau darauf aufzustülpen. Das muss natürlich
auch sein, wir müssen uns auch in diesem Raum
unterhalten. Aber ich glaube,
der erste Schritt wäre
grundsätzlich näher an den oder mit den Menschen
zusammenzuarbeiten,
die dann betroffen sind.
Das waren schon ein paar
Lösungsansätze, die können wir gleich vertiefen.
Gleich geht es weiter mit der Kompromiss
Runde, aber vorher möchte ich dir noch
eine letzte Frage stellen,
denn du bist dafür, dass Deutschland
innerhalb internationaler
Auslandseinsätze mehr Verantwortung übernehmen sollte.
Ich würde das gern noch einmal klären.
Was bedeutet denn mehr Verantwortung? Ich tu
mich schwer damit zu sagen, wir leben
in Deutschland, in einem demokratischen
System mit Freiheitsrechten und so
weiter, dass wenn wir noch mal an den Anfang
dieses Systems zurückdenken, nur existiert,
weil es eine militärische
Antwort gab auf auf ein autokratisches
Regime. Das ist die privilegierte
Situation, in der ich aufgewachsen bin,
in der viele andere von uns auch aufgewachsen
sind und wie gesagt, mit dem Ziel
"Frieden ohne Waffen" da will ich auf jeden Fall
auch zustimmen, aber bei uns hat es auch nicht
funktioniert. Ich versuche das immer
deshalb so zu erklären, warum sagen
wir jetzt in Deutschland, wir brauchen
eine größere Debatte dazu? Was ist der Deal
mit den internationalen Verbündeten?
Wenn ihr sagt, Deutschland sollte sich
nur auf Sanitätsleistungen, auf logistische
Unterstützungsleistungen einlassen?
Ich glaube, das wird nicht funktionieren
in den Militärbündnisses und politischen
Bündnissen, in denen wir aktuell sind.
Die NATO, der nukleare
Schutzschirm, unter dem Westeuropa ist, das sind
auch politische Übereinkünfte, wo man
dann sagen muss, wenn wir das nicht mehr
wollen, dann müssen wir das aufkündigen.
Dann muss es konsequent
sein und Deutschland schickt nur noch
Sanitäterinnen und Sanitäter in UN
Einsätze. Aber dann kann man eben
auch nicht mehr erwarten, dass die man sich
zurücklehnen kann, wenn es um Russland
geht oder um eine akute Bedrohung
in der östlichen Nachbarschaft, das ist
die Konsequenz davon. Michael, du bist
-einen großen Schritt zurückgegangen.
-Ja, also ich meine zum einen sieht man das
im Libyen-Einsatz, wo Deutschland
ja glücklicherweise nicht dabei war.
Und zum anderen würde ich einfach
sagen: Ja, man muss diese Debatte führen und dann
hoffentlich auch zu der Erkenntnis
kommen, dass das, was zum Beispiel die NATO
heutzutage macht und wie sie aufgebaut
ist und was sie für Ziele hat, dass das halt
-kontraproduktiv ist.
-Ich habe einen Kompromissvorschlag von mir
an euch und dem könnte er entweder zustimmen
oder ihr findet ihn nicht gut
und bleibt stehen oder geht bis ans
Ende des Feldes. Und danach könnt ihr jeweils
auf eurem Feld die Köpfe
zusammenstecken und euch einen eigenen Kompromissvorschlag
überlegen und ihn der anderen
Seite präsentieren. Aber vorher beginne
ich mit der elften Frage von 13
Fragen: Können wir uns darauf einigen,
dass wir die Bundeswehr aktuell
brauchen, ihre zukünftigen Aufgaben aber
in einer möglichst breiten
gesellschaftlichen Debatte besprochen
und definiert werden müssen? Also
nicht nur von Fall zu Fall im Bundestag,
sondern beispielsweise auch in einem
Gremium, in dem Menschen mitten
aus der Gesellschaft vertreten sind,
die sich mit dem Thema auf unterschiedlichste
Art und Weise schon befasst haben,
also zum Beispiel Menschen wie ihr. Ihr könnt
jetzt gerne einen Schritt auf mich
zugehen oder stehenbleiben oder zurückgehen.
Du bist keinen Schritt auf mich
zugegangen, richtig ja? Doch,
einen kleinen. ein kleinen
Minischritt. Michael, du hast das Feld verlassen.
Warum, Michael? Ich brauche die Bundeswehr
einfach nicht. Mattea, bist du jetzt noch
-mal einen Schritt zurück?
-Ne, ich glaube, ich bin ziemlich weit nach
vorne gegangen und wollte dann auch nicht
so ganz da vorne stehen, da habe ich mich
-so alleine gefühlt.
-Okay, dann ist noch ein bisschen Luft für
jetzt, denn jetzt könnt
ihr euch Kompromisse überlegen.
Ich meine, da haben wir auch unterschiedliche
Positionen
als Hilfsorganisationen besser
agieren könnten, bevor der Einsatz war stimmt ja
-nicht Nein.
-Schwieriges Thema. Am Ende sind meine
Gäste jetzt doch ein bisschen
aufeinander zugegangen. Ein bisschen Luft ist noch.
Und wenn ihr eine Idee habt, wie wir diese Luft
füllen könnten und die Gäste
ins Kompromissfeld bringen,
dann schreibt doch mal euren Kompromiss
-in die Kommentare.
-Aber eben kein Kompromiss wir haben Gut,
da werden wir uns nicht einigen. Das ist
so Banane Ich meine, wir sitzen hier
-als Kartoffeln.
-Sehr gut, dann bin ich gespannt auf eure
Kompromissvorschläge und fang mit euch
an, mit der grünen Seite. Was sagt ihr?
Also unser Kompromissvorschlag an euch
ist Bundeswehr im Auslandseinsatz: Ja,
aber mit einem klaren Auftrag, mit einer klaren
Zielsetzung, die humanitär
ausgerichtet ist, rein humanitär,
nicht als Angriffsarmee, nicht um militärische
und wirtschaftliche Interessen
durchzusetzen, sondern rein humanitär.
Das wäre unser Angebot. Und das auch nur nach einer Debatte,
im Bundestag
natürlich, wo eben Menschen
eingeladen werden aus den breiten
Bevölkerungsschichten, wo eben alle
Gruppen von Menschen eingeladen werden,
wo ich eben Veteranen höre, die aus Einsätzen
kommen und ihre Erfahrung
präsentieren. Und wir müssen natürlich
Bevölkerungsgruppen einbeziehen, die eben
geflüchtet sind zu uns und die daran
teilhaben müssen. Und wir müssen ganz
wichtig auch dort, die Deutsche
Friedensgesellschaft mit einbeziehen,
weil die Ideen, die die Werte
sind, grundsätzlich sehr gut, wie man
die umsetzen kann, darüber muss
man diskutieren. Alternativ kann es nicht
sein, wir schaffen alles ab und dann
ist Frieden, das funktioniert nicht.
Und daher ist unser Kompromissvorschlag:
Armee ja auch im Auslandseinsatz;
humanitäre Zwecke, Bezug zur Bevölkerung,
dass man darüber eine große Debatte führt
und dann mit einer klaren Zielsetzung,
die eben rein humanitär ausgerichtet ist.
Ihr könnt euch dann gern zu dem Kompromiss
positionieren, wenn ihr wollt. Also bist
du ein Schritt zurück jetzt gegangen?
Ja. Okay. Wieso? Weil es klingt nach einem
faulen Fisch. Und ehrlich
gesagt, ich finde das wahnsinnig wichtig,
diesen Debattenkreis zu öffnen.
Absolut und ich finde, es ist allerhöchste Zeit.
Ich finde aber natürlich immer
diese "Bundeswehr unter rein humanitären
Zwecken". Es gibt ja auch schon
tolle Sachen, die rein humanitär sind,
die im Katastrophenschutz aktiv sind,
die könnte man ja z.B. auch stärken. Da bin
ich nicht so ganz sicher, ob das nicht
dann am Ende, dass man da ein bisschen
die Katze im Sack kauft und am Ende
dann doch sehr, sehr viele Menschen in Uniform
hat, die vielleicht doch nicht so ganz
humanitär ausgerichtet sind, sondern eben
staatlich idealistisch.
Dann jetzt zu euch: Was ist denn
-euer Kompromissvorschlag?
-Wir haben sehr pragmatische Kompromisse,
zum Beispiel, dass wir selbstverständlich
mehr abrüsten müssen, also
dass Waffenexporte gestoppt werden,
dass wir mit internationalen Verträgen arbeiten
müssen, dass wir zum Beispiel
mehr finanzielle Mittel in Zivilen
Friedensdienst stecken müssen, dass nicht
so eine Diskrepanz zwischen militärischer
und ziviler Kräfte existiert,
dass zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement,
ob das in der Seenotrettung ist, in der Evakuierung,
in unterschiedlichen Formen
unterstützt werden muss, allerdings
ohne sich der Verantwortung zu entziehen
und dass wir vor allem dafür sorgen
müssen, da glaube ich, sind wir uns nicht
ganz einig, dass die Bundeswehr oder ein Bundeswehreinsatz
am Ende das allerletzte
Mittel wäre, wenn genau diese ganzen
zivilen und und ja und militärischen
-Mittel komplett ausgeschöpft sind.
-Ihr habt Kompromissvorschlag von dem
Gelben gehört. Habt ihr Interesse
daran, einen Schritt auf das andere Feld
zuzugehen? Ja, also ich würde
mich nur fragen, was wir dann mit unseren
Bündnispartnern machen.
Weil ich glaube, da kommen wir...-
Na ja, das muss man ja dann. Ich meine letzten
Endes ist das doch, jetzt mal
utopisch gedacht oder idealistisch
gedacht, genau das gleiche. Man sagt,
man geht in die zivile
Friedensverhandlungen und mediiert
zwischen Konfliktparteien. Ja, wir sind
hier auch in wahnsinnigen Ideen unterwegs,
aber man könnte auch da ja
genauso Verhandlungen führen, die,
die zu einer Versöhnung zu einander
kommen und die auch zu Kompromissen führen,
-wie hier.
-Zala, Andreas: geht ihr da auch ein
-Schritt zu oder bleibt ihr stehen?
-Mir kam grad die Idee dazu, was hier alle
drei gesagt habt: also die Bundeswehr
überführen, utopisch gedacht,
in eine Zivilgesellschaft, um die Aufgaben,
die sie einfach auch gut können,
dort auszuführen. Also ich bin jetzt
auch im Technischen Hilfswerk, daher kann
ich mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass die Aufgaben
auch in dem Rahmen durchzuführen.
Aber ich würde mich dennoch immer
unsicher fühlen, in einem Bürgerkriegsland
oder in einem Land, wo eben auch Gewalt
herrscht, ohne Waffen hinzugehen, um mich
selbst zu verteidigen oder eben andere
schutzbedürftige Personen zu verteidigen.
Da würde ich mich echt schlecht mit fühlen.
Wo wir uns drauf einigen könnten
wäre also ein bewaffnetes THW, im Grunde
genommen. Nennen wir es es Bundeswehr. Ja,
das können wir gerne Bundeswehr
nennen. Deswegen meine ich vorhin- Wir werden
die Waffen wieder- Wenn du da zustimmst,
kannst du ein Stück auf ihn zugehen
Moritz. -ja ich weiß, du bist dann
raus, aber ich rede jetzt nur mit ihm. Das ist
unser Kompromiss. Ich habe empfunden,
dass wir gar nicht so weit auseinander waren,
dass ich für mich mitgenommen habe,
was die zivile Seite eigentlich möchte.
Mehr humanitäres Engagement und weniger
militärisches und da bin ich auch voll
-bei dir.
-Grundsätzlich glaube ich, sollten wir
öfter solche Gespräche führen,
auch vielleicht in Zukunft miteinander.
Das wäre sicherlich sehr produktiv und vielleicht
machen wir dann in der Zukunft
-auch Dinge besser.
-Was ich auf jeden Fall noch einmal gemerkt
habe, das ist keine komplett neue
Erkenntnis, aber wie schlimm ist es,
wenn diese Debatten in der Öffentlichkeit
entweder unter den Teppich gekehrt werden
oder unehrlich geführt werden. Also,
wenn es eben genau um solche Dinge geht wie:
Was macht die Bundeswehr eigentlich
in Mali? Was war zu welchem Zeitpunkt des
Afghanistaneinsatzes welches Ziel?
Warum sind wir da? Weil, wir haben
auch gesprochen über die demokratische
Basis dafür und das ist auf jeden Fall
-nicht nicht genug gegeben.
-Ne, gibt es halt nicht, man liest einfach
nur: Ach, es geht jetzt wieder um Brunnen,
ging es nicht letztes Mal...? Ah,
-jetzt geht es um Frauen
-Ja und man macht es damit halt auch der
anderen Seite zu einfach zu sagen, da sind
Interessen, über die wird nicht gesprochen
und die sind wirtschaftlichen und die sind
.... Der Vorwurf lässt sich leicht
erheben, wenn man so öffentliche
Statements von der Politik hat wie:
"Super, Afghanistan war jetzt
erfolgreich" Man merkt, ihr hattet beide auf beiden
Seiten viele Kompromissvorschläge,
die heute gefallen sind und deswegen danke
ich euch erst mal, dass wir bis zu diesem Punkt
diskutiert haben. Ich danke euch.
Was wir, glaube ich, alle aus der Diskussion
mitnehmen können, ist,
dass wir mehr über dieses Thema
sprechen müssen in der Gesellschaft, untereinander,
in unseren Freundeskreisen. Und wenn ihr noch
weitere spannende Diskussionen sehen
wollt, dann lasst doch gerne ein Abo
für diesen Kanal da. Hier oben könnt
ihr ein weiteres Video von 13 Fragen
sehen und hier unten ein weiteres Video
zum Thema.